Looking at the figure, I can see I'm going to need to go to the right somehow
to get to the R vector. The V vector looks like a good place to start negated.
I put a negative 1 for this V vector. That got me going to the right. Now I
need to go upwards. I could add the vector N twice, but this would take me too
high. After adding N just once, I can see that I'm above the mirror surface. So
another N would take me beyond my goal of R. The vector dN looks like a winner
as this is essentially just the Y component of the V vector. Adding it to the
negated V vector is the same as simply moving to the right. Adding dN twice
gets us to the R vector, so two dN vectors are needed. The final formula then
is R equals 2 times dN minus V or to expand out R equals 2 times the dot
product of V and N, times N minus V.